all right speaking of the january what
do you get when you combine the words
vegan and
january you get the january yeah january
there you go that is the name for going
vegan and not
eating or using animal products for the
month of january
and rocky is live at go vegan cafe to
show us how it's done hey
hey guys yes first and foremost i want
to shout out the music in here we've got
some reggae playing these are the vibes
we need to bring in 2021 right
absolutely so this is lou she is the
manager here at go vegan cafe and we've
got a plethora of vegan items but first
i want to talk about veganuary
how do you guys celebrate here well we
encourage people to try going vegan for
a month
starting off the new year right for
themselves for the environment for lots
and lots of other reasons yeah and lots
of
restaurants do participate creating a
special veganuary menu
i love that and you know obviously for
january you have the special menus but
this is a lifestyle for you guys this is
all year round we've got
a market behind us we've got a juice bar
over there we've got a beautiful
outside seating area this is kind of a
one-stop shop for all things healthy
lifestyle
absolutely so tell us more about go
vegan cafe um
well we've been here for several years
and
we offer raw food cuisine which is a
little bit unique to what we do
and then we offer comfort food we
have breakfast served all day fresh
juices and smoothies of course the
market area
lots of delicious desserts and we try to
really support
other local small businesses by bringing
them in as vendors
so we try and really involve the
community and that's more important than
ever right now as we're dealing with
this pandemic so let's talk about i'm
just
basically how people can start obviously
we're 11 days into january but you can
start a little later how can they start
and jumpstart this vegan january well
vegansbaby.com is a great resource
you can see all of the hundred percent
vegan restaurants in town there are
probably about 40 of them now
say that website one more time
vegansbaby.com vegansbaby.com okay noted
yeah and also um lots of omni
restaurants are
are learning that vegans are larger and
larger populations now
so they must cater to them so if they
have more than three items on their
menu specifically vegan intentionally
created not just
oh can you make this vegan for me then
vegan's baby will go and promote that
business as well that's
awesome so let's get into the food okay
because
that is sausage and that is bacon and
it's vegan correct so just talk about
the dishes really quick
sure this is our breakfast feast here
it's a scrambled potato
sausage and bacon with a short stack of
pancakes
lots of options so you get to customize
it we have
our chili and caesar salad and then we
also have a raw feast for a lot of
people they've never
tried raw cuisine other than a salad and
so it's a great way to try a few
different items that is our
raw tostada beautiful raw wrap
wrapped in a collard green leaf and our
house salad which did win the best salad
in the city several years in a row
congratulations well listen i am
enjoying this vegan sausages i've never
had vegan sausage so
um you're selling me coming up later in
the four o'clock we're gonna get to the
juice bar
and see how we can stay healthy
holistically right absolutely thank you
lou
thank you rocky i call dibs on those
pancakes on that table make sure uh
bring those back please thank you and
we'll check back in with you during the
four o'clock newscast